thrilled to have a baseball
hall-of-famer who can be caught on MLB
Network tonight and Tuesday from
Nationals Park one of the all-time
greats Baseball Hall of Famer Pedro
Martinez great to see you Pedro well
thank you for having me it's great
seeing you too
there you bet so what what what memories
does that bring up for you when you see
that 99 all-star start in Fenway Park
well before the game I remember shaking
a lot I've never seen planes in an
all-star game flights or low standing on
the mound you know and I'm warming up
and when the planes went by after the
anthem you know I'm I'm almost done okay
getting up right the fly off hey I did
not expect the planes to fly so low and
they kind of shoot me and should be
entire stadium it was like the most
amazing sound I I've ever heard and then
you know just watching the all century
team to me was great I was unbelievable
I remember Hank Aaron coming over and
wanting to shake my hand and not to me
that was like oh my god this is it but
it got even better because after the
game the game I knew what I could do I
was facing those guys during that era
that what I was able to do inhabited
Williams come bring me over to his suite
where he was actually there's a little
video I don't know where it is the Red
Sox habit where he says you one hell of
a pitcher and he took my hand and he
signed the program and that was pretty
much my trophy that that capped it out I
think just being part of the most unique
all-star game that I that I can think of
have the old century players something
we might not see in this lifetime it's
probably the most amazing gift I could
ever get in an all-star game forget
about the strikeouts forget about the
performance an all-star game like that
deserves that and probably even better
because I just remember that after the
all century team had been announced and
then the players had been announced I'm
assuming you're warming up in the
bullpen is that where you were it was
it's about it was always delayed
remember how everybody mopped over well
that was it yeah they they asked the
announce the public address announcer
asked you essentially you guys to break
it up yeah I was already and you know
walk into the bullpen but he was so
delayed because everybody wanted to hug
Ted Williams that I had to actually hold
myself from pitching something I did not
like but because it was an all-star game
you're flexible to doing anything and if
it was in a regular game I'll be pissed
and everybody right it was the all
century team it was dedicated to Ted
Williams to me was an honor to just be
part of anything that that happened that
day if I'm not mistaken Bob Gibson was
out there too
everybody acts cool facts Roger Clemens
Ken Griffey all the players are what yes
that were from the old century team and
at the same time well life some of them
I passed away since then unfortunately
but I I was really happy to take part in
that all-star game the most unique
all-star game that we could probably we
will ever see a I agree I agree with you
Pedro yeah I was there any thought of
you not going to innings just doing one
was there no I was there to pitch I was
representing Boston I was representing
Ted Williams I I was I was in perfect
timing to go pitch it was it was just
amazing everything was amazing about
that all-star game it was also a
learning lesson for me how so well I I I
learned to keep my composure you know
but forgetting about the hype because
there was a lot of hype in that all-star
game I learned to keep my composure they
delay and all that I figured it didn't
have to affect my game the way I thought
it would
by someone delaying or you know throwing
me back on time so I try to learn from
everything I did and that was a game
that really taught me how to be patient
and wait for my time it's interesting
you say paid Pedro Martinez all Famer
and again on MLB Network tonight
tomorrow from Nationals Park all
enjoy your work that you do with the TBS
as well thank and here in the Rich Eisen
show where you said if it was a regular
season game he'd be pissed our current
day pitchers that way do they have that
mindset do you think Pedro and to me the
most stressful day was the day before a
pitch and why is that because I wanted
to get it over with I wanted to go after
the hitters and I wanted to be up there
and I didn't even want to wait one
second I just wanted to go after you and
I had a hard time dealing with that
because I prepare myself I got ready and
I just wanted to go out there and
compete and kind of have the day and a
half I had to kind of relax for me
baseball if I had known better like I
know now I would enjoy it a lot more but
back in those days it was like a
stressful I wanted to just go up you
know go about my business get it done
with and then kind of relaxed and and I
didn't enjoy it as much I was always
cutting a block of ice and trying to go
and compete
instead of having fun who is it work
toughest down for you yeah who is the
toughest out for you I think we're all
tough rich oh come on you know that's
not an excuse I will not accept that and
all believe me but there were guys that
were pesky Jesus I remember facing the
number one to me was Edgar Martinez
because oh yeah our picture in a small
frame I wanted to be economic actually
99 I was really economic the entire
season I was expecting that to happen
for the rest of my career and some of
those guys were somehow found a way to
fall off pitches mhm fouled off good
quality pitches that you were supposed
to get other people out right and and
Edgar was one of the best are doing that
Derek Jeter another pesky player pesky
pesky but professional I didn't like
facing Alomar guys like that Kenny
Lofton I shall fall off little pitches
and would roam like my count hi well you
know a lot of folks think Edgar should
be in that that beautiful music
you and I know he should be an I do
agree I do agree he you know I've full
disclosure uh I'm a native New Yorker
and a die-hard Yankee fan so so was I
know hold on a second wait a minute what
is this rich you don't know this clearly
I'm the only Yankee fan that ever paid
all 250 bucks that he made while playing
for the Dodgers enable for a Reggie
Jackson sign ball so you tell me if you
would do that when you only had was 250
bucks yeah coming out of the Dominican
yes and you paid all 250 bucks that you
had for ready Jackson sign ball would
you do that
no I would not do that day and I was
that big of a fan already jack but if I
was that big of a fan of Reggie Jackson
then I wouldn't have tried to beat the
Yankees as much as I tried me three
times the Yankees is that right yeah
that was the first team I asked to be
traded to and what happened didn't fall
didn't fold the trade did not want shame
as you see this Red Sox hat on by the
way on the other side of the glass is my
entire family who are my wife from
Boston and my nephew Jack who's fired up
to meet you and all those kids they're
all flipping out right now that you're
still no but see that same year I got my
reality check because I got a couple of
friends traded wait a minute wait a
minute now instead of a Dodger might be
a Yankee or might be a red sock right I
quit being a fan then okay once you know
you were a trading piece like taking
this ball and moving it from one hand to
the next you quit being a fan mm-hmm and
you become the player because at that
moment I didn't know if I was gonna make
it with the Dodgers if I don't make it
with with the Cubs who knows so you quit
being a fan and then you you face the
game because I still are a ball you
still are a fan you know like like I saw
stressful talking about Tony Gwynn the
other day gave me goose
because he wanted to be like Donna green
anything he's now a national right right
and he wanted to be like Tony and he
became a picture and playing for the
national never never got the opportunity
to be drafted by San Diego are you aware
of what Edgar Martinez career batting
average against you us are you know I
have that number him I did not stop to
look at numbers I I will tell you you
say is the tough one of the toughest
outs you ever had
yes 120 career batting average against
you so that says that it doesn't matter
what you do against me is how I feel you
were against me and I felt like Hager
was really tough and he wanted you to
make mistakes you know I was really
little reluctant to make mistakes
mm-hm and he was one of those person
that would force you to do to commit a
mistake in order for him to feast on you
Jeter was 271 against you another tough
okay I'll tell you who I'm my number
though who Mike Piazza he did six
dingers see there now that's a number
you definitely remember that I don't
feel I like that uncomfortable like he
was uncomfortable he will get it done
one or two pitches maybe three it's the
most he's ever you've ever given up to a
single I think so I think that's true
385 he's hitting it against you kill me
I'm getting all this stuff fed every
bones also did really well against me
okay but I want to take a break and
finish up the hour with you if that's
okay let's talk about a little bit of
current current baseball activity with
one of the all-time greats Pedro
Martinez Baseball Hall of Famer MLB
Network TBS right here in the Rich Eisen
we're back here on the Rich Eisen show
couple more minutes with Pedro Martinez
having a lot of fun with you sir why did
you leave the Red Sox what happened
because I made the biggest mistake a
naturally to make well is baseball has a
dark side that a lot of people don't
know and and that dark side might be
affecting right now Dellin Betances when
you when you have to go to arbitration
the teams have to look for negative
things about you some of us have the
skin to to take it some other people are
more sensitive I made a huge mistake
during my negotiations you know for I
kept going back and forth well we're
gonna keep a drop it you know what I did
what I was like like I'm saying it now
like I always said from my heart
everything I said I meant in baseball
including the bat quotes that you
probably got very few of them but they
were honest honest quotes I said my best
interest is in Boston when you're
negotiating in front of an arbitrator or
in front of people business people the
business part of baseball's dark because
his money and his business is not
baseball I spoke about business the way
I felt about baseball and about the fan
base in about the team so I went my best
interest is to stay in Boston I don't
want to leave I want to stay I was
willing to take a pay cut to stay in
Boston even though I had an outstanding
year
yes shilling had a better year but I had
a pretty good year I've done everything
including risk my career for Boston and
I was too open to say I would just stay
in Boston I know I'm not leaving guess
what that led me to getting the worst
offer the Boston can ever ever offer and
Boston is a team that normally paced
Boston and the Yankees are some of the
teams that paid probably the best in the
market and I was too open when it came
to negotiation the end is son advice for
the young players
never open yourself up when it comes to
business keep it quiet
whatever fill you up don't say it
because they will try to take advantage
of it and Sophie or her dad and Luke II
know and they were like this guy is
gonna go to the extremes to actually
stay with us and that was my mistake and
you left I left because the offer I got
I thought was disrespectful at the time
I at that time it made me angry because
I couldn't believe that they would take
me that low and I I just said no you
have 15 days to match whatever other
offer I get and I got an offer right
away I said you have 15 days to get it I
already have what I want
mm-hmm they couldn't believe it and they
didn't match it they didn't match it no
on time and I gave my word to someone
else which was the first Dominican DM
Omar Minaya who on Thanksgiving Day was
sitting with me not with his family
trying to get me to agree that if I
didn't get in 15 days with Boston I was
gonna stay with them with the Mets
instead and that's the main reason why I
didn't sign with the Yankees because I
did have the proper offer from the
Yankees and even more if the way they
treated gaming the way they treated but
I was also aware of that and it wasn't
the fan based fault that I was leaving I
know it was a business decision from the
team and later on I realized it you know
I try to learn from everything and
that's when I realized that I was a bad
businessman at that adapt I shall never
be in so outspoken about my feelings
with the team and that led to me not
getting what I wanted or getting the
proper offer because if it was close to
what I got with Omar I would have stayed
with Boston well I hope it's the first
of many times that we get to hang on
this show and otherwise page we're gonna
be hanging around I'm learning I'm
learning haha
from you guys masters Pedro Martinez
foundation.com for at-risk youth and
families in the Dominican Republic great
right terrific work that you are doing
in your foundation and certainly on
television I really enjoy watching your
Pedro well thank you really make me
smart here till you tell me stuff that
I'm not seeing that I I might not know
that's well I'm learning from you too
that's that's that's a good thing yeah I
just dropped a little message to the
next generation of players hmm don't
confuse feelings with business you are
teaching me out of know about this and
learn from all of you I thank you very
much thank you me I know I noticed you
follow me on Twitter now and I'm right
yes yes for Twitter buddies now the
amount of memories this guy has given me
I'll never be able to pay him back or or
or forget so thank you so much at 45
Pedro Martinez on Twitter as well the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience